foreign
I can be in a parking lot going five
miles an hour if I get in an accident
going five miles an hour it's fine but
in my insane brain I picture fatalities
and fire I want you to reframe this this
is not your crazy brain this is your
ride on been there brain
[Music]
[Applause]
greatest mental health in marriage and
relationship parenting show ever so glad
that you joined us listen one of the
greatest ways you can support us with no
money no money no anything like when
asking to mail us anything although if
you want to mail stuff that's super fun
when I get mail
um just subscribe to the show whether
you watch on YouTube or on podcast if
you'll just subscribe to it you'll send
it to people that you that you know and
love or send it to people who are
struggling with sleep and you want to
help them get off
um their sleep meds this show can do
that for them too and leave a five star
review
um send your three star reviews to Jenna
Sears and um the five star reviews you
can keep here be so great
um um just I'm appreciative for you I'm
grateful for you thank you so much for
doing that send the show out
um let's go to the phones let's just get
right to it let's go to Renee in Falling
Waters West Virginia I'm glad it's not
Rising Waters West Virginia how are you
Renee I'm fantastic how are you good
that would not be good if it was Rising
Waters all right so what's up
all right so I'll jump into my question
how can I train
to not catastrophize everything that I
am not in control of Renee that's one of
my favorite things to do why would you
want to give that up it's exhausting I'm
so good I know but it's so fun it's so
fun what if I know but what if like what
if that's like the haunt question right
right all right what do you
catastrophize why do you do that
foreign
what I think it stems from we'll give
you a little background when I was five
years old I was in a vehicle accident
that killed my mom
and from that point Renee why didn't you
start there
I'm not laughing at your mom passed away
I was laughing I think I found it uh
right I think this is
the
thing
so
I mean it's everything so in car rides I
can be in a parking lot going five miles
an hour and I know in my mind that is
logical if I get in an accident going
five miles an hour it's fine but in my
insane brain I picture
fatalities in Fire and explosions
um you know I'm afraid of turning my
phone off because I'm convinced as soon
as I do it something's gonna happen in
my family someone will be trying to get
a hold of me and they'll be a big thing
um when my daughter goes with her father
I'm convinced she's going to get
kidnapped or they'll be in an accident
or something will happen then I'm not
there to control or keep from happening
um
yeah like things like that so I want you
to reframe this this is not your crazy
brain
this is your ride on bin there brain
right
this is your brain doing the best job it
can to keep you safe
and good for it
good for it and here's a weird thing
about it you know what it feels like
it's kept you from dying in a car wreck
for the last 25 years
so far so as far as it's concerned it's
done its job
right right and then the
the spin up part of your brain is like
so far but it could be today
and here's here's here is the the
damning loop that you're in
you're right
your daughter could get kidnapped
that could actually happen
you could actually get in a fiery
burning car wreck do you think that's
gonna happen
logically
logically no yep right so the magic is
how do we get to yeah that could happen
but probably not
and the the sentence that that little
phrase has was part of my getting well
journey and I still is with me now
which is or not my journey and it sounds
like I'm some like on some spiritual
Voodoo one but like on the adventure
from going from a super anxious over
catastrophizer to how do I just be a
like a well-adjusted joyful dad
co-worker and friend and husband
is the sentence but probably not and I
got that from a banker I didn't get that
from a therapist I got it from my
buddy's a banker and I was like yeah
what about this and he goes oh okay that
could happen and he goes but probably
not and I realized oh yeah I'm just
staring at this one little sliver of pie
and I'm forgetting all the other pile
around it
um
have you
gone and done something like EMDR
no
I think you should
okay and this is not me telling you this
clinically this is me telling you as a
friend
what you have yet to do is metabolize
the trauma that you experienced
firsthand and by the way it's not just
that car wreck it's your body's memory
of
being a tethered tether-free
five-year-old kid without a mom
and it's easy to put all of this onto
Vehicles onto CarX but it's way bigger
than that
the trauma here is way bigger than that
the trauma is a little five-year-old
girl that was stumbling through the
world saying
but where's my mom
right and your body has to be able to
have that memory and ask that question
and have that thought and not take off
on you as though the wreck is happening
again
yeah does that make sense it does so
healing here is not that your mom comes
back healing here isn't that you didn't
experience the single most horrific
thing a child could experience which is
the death of their mother
being in it and horrific one second
you're here one second she's gone
healing is I can remember that I can
think of that and my body knows I'm safe
in the present and that's what something
like EMDR can do a good therapist can
help you with that we're just trying to
make peace with
the present we weren't safe then but
we're safe now
and then here's the worst part that's
the worst part about catastrophizing the
only way to heal from it is right
through it
right right that's the worst it's the
worst it's the worst the only way to get
over a phobia is to hold a snake and
realize it's not going to kill you it
could it might but it probably won't I
probably will
and here did you hear how flipping I am
about it and now it's just become second
nature right my wife is four minutes
late she could be cheating on me yep but
she's probably not you know I mean right
um so it's now it's just a it's just an
automated it's an automated statement in
my mind
um here's the place I want you to start
number one I want you to get how old are
you
32 32 okay so I want you to call a
counselor who specializes in the EMDR
try there start there in your local area
um and you may have to travel a little
bit this isn't something I don't think
you can do EMDR I've never heard of it
being done
um on uh
uh like Zoom or something right
um but I want you to find a counselor in
your area that can do it okay
um and say I was a part of a
catastrophic wreck as a kid and I am
continuing to replay that
um it sounded like tell me if I'm wrong
it sounded like just when I was talking
about a little five-year-old girl
missing her mom your body started you
got choked up there
oh absolutely okay that's what we're
looking for okay
that's where the that's the the center
that's the engine of the catastrophizing
foreign still thinks it has it can do a
thing that will keep your mom okay
your body still thinks okay mom's gone
we are on our own
and the way through our own uh the way
through this is we will control
everything and when your brain feels
like you're not paying enough attention
it's gonna start playing movies in the
foreground to make you pay attention
yes and we're just going to turn that
that part of your brain off and let it
be where it should be which is
identifying real threats not ones that
are imagined
the second thing I want you to do is I'm
holding this up if you're watching this
on YouTube
uh it's just get a journal of some sort
something small that you can write down
the wildest of the wild thoughts
okay okay and sometimes I I do it much
less
um now but occasionally I do it I'll
hold them at arm's length so I can look
at them
and I just ask myself one question is
this true
and 99.9 percent of the time it's it
might be but probably not
right
and there's going to be real threats in
the world
right like right now Everything feels
like 1917.
a small little conflict started over and
you know in Russia and then last night
or two nights ago Putin mobilizes a
bunch of troops and then somebody has a
failed assassination over it feels like
the world's turning into a powder keg
and we're waiting on one spark to set it
off right yeah
um
so There's real stuff
but I want my body to be able to focus
through the noise at those things the
things I can actually they're actually
real threats and by the way what I can
actually do about them that's the other
part that's that's part two identifying
those thoughts is this true and then
underneath it what can I do about it
yeah and that's where we're going to
focus you know what I can do about
Russia invading you crazy apps zero
things I can do zero things
yeah
zero zero zero zero
that makes sense it does yes I wish I
could give you a thing that just stopped
it
right but it's actually not a bug in the
system it's your brain trying to take
care of you
what's your biggest let's hey let's do
this one together what's your biggest
catastrophe
what's the thing you catastrophize the
most
uh something happening to my kids
and me not being there it could be
anything
oh your body's you've been through that
story
yeah
it was hellacious not having your mom
wasn't it
oh yes
something could happen to you but it
probably won't
right
so what can you do about it
and that's that's an honest question and
I'm thinking like not texting and
driving and wearing a seatbelt and
not drinking and drying what are some
things you can do about it
control
the more specific you can itemize things
the more your
um The Fear Part of your brain will
realize you're driving
meaning if for a season you have a
little note card in your car that just
says have I done all the things yep yep
I've done what I can do
okay you can't do anything about a drunk
driver
right you can't do anything about
somebody running a red light
you can make sure your seat belts on you
can make sure you're not intoxicated you
make sure I don't text and drive
make sure all my kids are in uh their
car seats and then that's what I can do
and what we're going to do is we're
going to practice Making Peace there but
if you're in the car driving and you're
wondering did I do everything I could do
do I do everything and now your brain's
like who's driving and then out of the
back of your brain I'll take over and
then the story start right yeah
so what can I actually do in a nuclear
Holocaust not not a lot you know I mean
not a lot yeah
um I I'll have some canned goods I guess
and there's a local there's a creek down
the street from me I'll go there right I
mean so it's like very limited and it's
like okay so not a lot
right and uh
just making peace with it are you scared
to go back and deal with it
uh no I don't think so all right let me
see it like this not that you're scared
like I don't know what to do uh more
like I'm scared that if I finally deal
with this Mom leaves
all right
let me tell you what's on the other side
of this thing
you haven't laughed for real in a long
time
foreign
and you probably Renee haven't slept
in full crash course deep REM sleep and
beneath that the deep sleep
prob possibly ever
you haven't been able to prop your feet
up in a relationship and just settled in
you might be married and be in love and
he loves you or whatever but to be
completely at peace because you've been
making sure nobody comes busting in the
door to kill everybody
that's what we're aiming for here
you're worth it you're worth it you're
worth it
we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back hey before I run
to the next call
um
EMDR stands for eye movement
desensitization and reprogramming
it's a technique people do with a pin or
with some sort of instrument or some
following some something with your eye
recalling the trauma and it um
has proven anecdotally I haven't read
the data on it recently but anecdotally
it's um
people I've met with over the years have
just reported being magic quite frankly
um really an important part of healing
from trauma and this is a weird thing
I've had people reach out with some odd
regularity on social media asking
do I trust it is it safe can people of
Faith do EMDR I don't know what people
think it is well they maybe they're
getting confused with DMT or some sort
of like psychedelic thing but
um
absolutely I can't wrap my head around
any possible reason a person of Faith
would not be into embr it's an
incredible healing modality it doesn't
work for everybody but it's something I
would recommend if you've got trauma
that you've experienced recently or in
the past and you're trying to bring your
body into the present well leaving the
memories where they were integrating
those memories into your life in a
non-threatening way
um eye movement desensitization
reprogramming EMDR
um Can Work wonders often especially if
the trained therapist knows what they're
doing so
um check in on that if that's something
that's good for you check out a local
provider in your area and um see if that
it brings you some healing all right
let's go to Kyler in Layton what's up
Kyler
hey Dr John how's it going good man
what's up
oh I'll just I'll start with my question
and then I'll provide some backstory
after that
um so my wife and I we've been married
for about five months and we're in the
process of
adopting my two-year-old nephew
my question is because why not why not
why why wouldn't we right why wouldn't
we just pile on well just say like so
when somebody says we're hot we're we're
adopting our nephew here's what that
says to me
family is a train wreck
um it's a mess we got picked or we
stepped in and said we're dealing with
this and we now and if you put that on
top of we've been married five months
this is incredible go ahead keep going
am I right
uh pretty much I've got one side of the
family that is a little more
dysfunctional than the other but don't
wait don't we all don't we all that's
right that's right
um so my question is how do we set
effective boundaries for not only the
biological parents but also for the rest
of the family
um okay and this all kind of
spearheaded about couple weeks ago we
made the decision that we want to change
this child's name
he's named after my brother
um
we feel like that name was kind of
it's mounted in trauma he hasn't had a
great start to his life and
we want to start a new chapter
um
and that that part of that is his name
for us
so
my other brother got involved I have two
older brothers the middle one is the
biological father and then my oldest one
I sort of feel like they're ganging up
on me and my wife
um I feel like I'm disrespecting
um the biological father by changing the
name
um and everyone seems to have this
opinion and to be quite Frank Dr John I
don't care for anyone's opinion I'm just
trying to survive yeah so I'm trying to
do the best that I can
let's be a hundred percent candid
ate
that you are disrespecting your older
brother I'm not suggesting he doesn't
deserve that
but looking at him saying I'm taking
your son from you because you can't
handle this child or you're abusing this
child is child's not safe with you so
I'm going to become this child's new dad
and I don't even want him
he's not your name isn't even worthy of
this kid so I'm taking it off
like yeah that's I mean that's a slap in
the face to anybody's kid ABS absolutely
and I'm not saying he doesn't have the
right to be hurt
um or anything like that
um
I just I feel like I've done research
I've talked to people who have been who
have been both adopted and have gone to
the adoption process
um the caseworkers have told me it might
be a good idea to start with
um I don't feel like this was just uh oh
I hate my brother kind of a thing I love
no no no I don't I don't think I don't
think that at all um here's what I think
uh
I think you haven't fully thought
through
what let me let me say it this way by
adopting this kid
you are opting out of the family as it
normally operates
and I don't think you fully absorbed
that yet or metabolize that
your family cannot and will not function
as it once did
and I think what you're doing is noble
and the right thing
just the way family was done before is
over
and your your Middle Brother the brother
the father of this child feels like they
got a loophole which is they're gonna
have access to their kid and still be
the dad they don't have to do any of the
Dead work
and so if you're gonna truly be the the
uh
parent and guardian of this kid there's
gonna have to be some space and distance
between biological dad also knowing that
in our current world there is no way to
have deny access Forever at some point
right that little boy wants to know who
my dad really is and why am I not with
my dad what was so bad about me that dad
left me
right
and so here's what I'm trying to take
take the
romance out of this
this is gonna be hard
right
and everybody's gonna have to act like
an adult I hate that your oldest brother
isn't
um
who didn't step up and offer to take
this kid I'm sad that he thinks he can
armchair quarterback this deal
you see what I'm saying yeah yeah
absolutely I heard that for you so do
y'all all live together do y'all live by
each other
uh my two brothers they live in Salt
Lake they live right near each other so
we're probably 20 minutes 30 minutes
away and then my wife and I live
um a little further north but okay it
may be considering that Utah is not for
you guys for a while okay
that's I and I'm thinking through I'm
just all I'm doing I don't have any data
or any sort of research to back this up
I'm just trying to put myself exactly in
your position what I would do
like you're talking about changing his
name that tells me that there are some
deep reasons that we are cutting ties
foreign
and so
you can't cut some of the ties and hope
all the time the rest of the ties just
untangle themselves it's just not how
they work
what do your parents think about all
this
um
my dad
um he is a recovering addict so he's
kind of in and out of jail but
um he's been sober lately and he is I
I'm just gonna stop you right there like
he didn't get a vote and I don't say
that I don't say that mean but he's
sober right now so he used to be dead
for a few months while he's clean that's
just not how that works
he can't toggle in and out you're a guy
that's been on your own for a long time
aren't you
um I've had a great mom she's been a
single mom and she's
she's amazing
but I am kind of a the caretaker of the
family
so you made a bold move and again the
words I'm using can be taken either way
I'm taking this as a good thing you took
a you made a bold and brave move you
can't you can't care for this child I
will thank you
did the court take him away or did he
did your brother surrender him to you
and he eventually
um after a couple of months he was going
to the parenting plan and not kind of
doing what he needed to be doing and he
then signed him over to us okay
but I mean that was with an agreement um
I I didn't take his child
um that was never the intention and we
had many conversations
beforehand like what this would look
like is he an addict
um I think he has a marijuana problem I
don't know if he does anything else my
oldest brother and I grew up with my mom
and then he kind of grew up in many
different households because he was
living with my dad okay
so he had a little bit tough for
upbringing
let me back out of because I'm going on
a rabbit hole here let me back out a
little bit okay
I would be willing to bet that you and
your wife had your own independent
pictures of what Parenthood was going to
look like
oh yeah and that you you and your wife
also had very clear pictures of what
your first couple years of marriage was
going to be like dude y'all were going
to be doing it all the time
and wherever wherever it doesn't matter
and y'all are gonna go on vacations and
do cool stuff and pay off your debts
y'all can do all kind of stuff
and now it's gonna look different
already out of the gate and where I see
couples get sideways is they go do a
unified thing together
but the way it was going to look and
feel while they were doing this thing
they miss each other
right and so you and your wife have to
constantly stay connected
this week looks different how do you
want this to look last week looked
different how do you want this one
upcoming one to look you all got to stay
really plugged in together on this
we're really trying we do what you
recommend kind of every Sunday morning
we sit down we have breakfast we talk
about how the week's going good oh it's
so good dude is that helping
it's helping so much
um we went through a bit of a rough
patch we were pretty stressed
um in the beginning I say in the
beginning we've only been married for
five months so I guess it's the
beginning but dude if you've already
figured it out after five months you win
write that book you'll be you'll be rich
right there
we're trying to we're trying to
um um yeah this little boy's life can
only be as good as you and your wife are
connected
and that's a controversial statement I
don't care
I I agree 100 and and we do I mean my
mom and my wife's mom are very good
about watching him so we can call on
date nights awesome once a week we try
to do that awesome we're trying to keep
our lives
um you know over 22 and 24 so we're
still trying to be
young but fun or but parents can I tell
you like of all the things like
everything you're doing is noble and you
are it's going to be hard and it's going
to be messy and it sounds like you don't
know what's coming but you know
something hard is coming and you're
stepping in that Gap anyway which is
awesome
I can't get my head around changing that
little boy's name tell me about that
[Music]
like here's what it feels like it feels
like an immature attempt to erase
something that you can't erase
that might be true like like I said I'm
22 and I'm I'm not and we haven't done
anything yet and if if people are
speaking into my life that I trust are
saying don't do it then it would be
something we would reconsider but
what it comes down to is this little boy
has been neglected
um he was taken from his home for 32
days
um my brother my brother really let him
down
um and it breaks my heart to to hear
that name
called to my I mean he's my son Dr John
it breaks my heart to see that name or
hear that name associated with a new
with what I consider a new baby he's
he's new and it's not that I want to
erase my brother and it's not that he
won't know at a very very young age that
she was adopted and this was a situation
and your dad loves you and this is who
he is it's not that we want to keep him
from him it's just that I think this
this baby deserves a new beginning
um and this is this is kind of the way I
thought it might be a good idea it
sounds like the babies not the one that
needs a new beginning it sounds like you
do
can you elaborate on that
you're the one that can't stand to hear
that name not him
yeah
yeah that's probably true
um
here's I don't have any skin in that
game
I don't have any skin in that game
um
if the if the
people in your life who have kids who
are speaking into your life the mentors
you have and I would ask non-family
mentors okay
um I don't know what what your faith
background is I don't know what your
cultural background is I don't know any
of those things that would lend itself
to the power and importance of a name so
I don't feel good about speaking into it
other than to say this feels a lot more
about you than it does this kid
and I want you to make sure you never
use your kid
to make you feel better about yourself
or ever do things with this kid so that
you feel better about fill in the blank
and if you can learn this lesson at 22
and 23 at 25 you will be so far ahead of
other dads me included
um but this little boy will know this
for his entire life that half of me is
my mom and half of me is my dad
and the demon when dads leave their kids
or dads choose to
uh or unable to I'll say it that way uh
keep their kids
is that kid asks forever is half of me
bad too
is half of me capable of leaving too
and so your love and your connection is
going to be it's gonna be a Lifeline to
this kid on top of that question
underneath that question to the side of
that question that will haunt him for a
lot of his life
and
I don't know I have to think about that
one I've never heard that in my whole
life somebody's saying I'm adopting
somebody in my family and I've changed
the name because
this kid is better than your name
um ask some people in your community in
your in your cultural background in your
faith community the wisdom on that
um
just check yourself is this new name a
new start for this baby or is this new
name start for me when it comes to your
wife
um man you are on the path it just
continue to check in
and create a culture that when she says
I need this or I'm scared about this or
I have a gut feeling that so and so is
going to show up and try to take this
kid tonight or so-and-so gets drunk and
I don't want to run my kid that you are
able to go I hear you let's see if we
can make this happen
and and vice versa that y'all are
constantly working through that it's
gonna be a rough go no question it's
gonna be a rough go
sounds like y'all are the right folks to
do it
being as young as you are and as newly
wedded as you are surround yourself with
mature couples who are 10 years 15 years
20 years down the road from you and make
sure you've got people that you trust
that you can ask wise counsel from
thank you so much for being a guy that
steps up in his community that's you're
a blessing we'll be right back
hey good folks Dr John deloney here can
we all just take a minute to take a deep
breath
ah there's a lot going on in our homes
our neighborhoods and across the world
and it might be stressing you out I know
I'm more stressed than usual but
remember we've been through Seasons like
this before and the best thing we can do
is to focus on controlling what we can
control
you can control your spending your
saving how much time you're spending on
electronics you can control your daily
habits and you can control making time
for sleep this one is easy to forget
especially when you're stressed but
sleep is key to taking care of your
physical and mental health and I have
found the key to great sleep is a great
mattress and that's why I love dream
Club mattresses they're so comfortable
and right now dream cloud is making it
easy to invest in good sleep with a
great deal 599 dollars in accessories
plus an additional 250 discount that's a
total of 849 dollars in accessories and
savings go to dreamcloudsleep.com
deloney or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today
all right let's take one more let's go
to Diane and one of my favorite cities
in America Santa Fe New Mexico what's up
Diane
you today so good how are you
doing good thank you so much of course
what's up
hi
um just a little bit of background
um I'm a disabled veteran I participated
in Desert Storm
and I'm going to be 58 in a few days I'm
a fiscal year baby
and in May I graduated with dual
master's degrees I have an MSW and an
MBA from a State University okay
um the kicker is that two weeks before
graduation my new VA doctor told me that
I had been diagnosed with ADHD but I was
never notified totally fell through the
cracks
because why not right way to go VA way
to go
you have this I'm like oh great
my University was extremely difficult
but I got through
um I also have generalized anxiety
disorder um I believe that's part of the
ADHD as well
um I was always blue in pink color in
the past I always worked factory jobs
and office jobs I always had trouble
with jobs and with taking care of my
personal affairs so I have a patchy life
of great success and spectacular failure
both
and now I'm a white collar professional
for the first time in my life and I'm
getting ready for a new job in two weeks
I'm terrified to go into a new
professional job and mess up because of
the ADHD impulsiveness lack of social
skills No Boundaries no sense of time
procrastination all of those classic
symptoms
um I did just start Ritalin with the
help of my new VA doctor she's wonderful
I'm on a waiting list for therapy
how do I make this new transition a
success for my new team for the people
I'm going to be caring for and for
myself awesome awesome question
I think you're awesome by the way Diane
thank you I think you are too well I'm
I'm a YouTuber let's be honest I'm not
that good like I want Tick Tock for
God's sake uh you
the people you sit down to love
are so blessed because you're in their
life
I'm glad you've made this transition
um have you heard me talk about my mom's
story
no I haven't okay I'll do this in 30
seconds and we'll get to your answers
but here's some encouragement for you uh
my mom didn't go to Kyle uh just for a
number of reasons
um didn't go to college First Community
College class was age 42.
she graduated her PhD at 57 so y'all are
basically the same boat
wow at 62 63 she got tenured as a
professor at some fancy University and
she's in her 70s and she just where I
was talking to her the other night and
she's like yeah I'm going to be teaching
at Oxford next summer
dude this is a lady that would not get
on an airplane minus nine Xanax and now
she's flying all over the world in her
70s teaching it fancy see what I'm
saying so here's what I want to
encourage you the party's just getting
going Diane
that's wonderful to hear yeah it's too
late no no you got no all right here's
what you've got to do
you've got to cool it with the labels
okay
dunskis no more Blue Collar White Collar
I'm of this not of that here's the deal
you've had ADHD your whole life you
didn't just get it two weeks before it
graduated
you you're right you rattled off a
series of symptoms that fell into a
diagnostic category
and somebody went Wham and stamped your
chart with a stamp
you've been dealing with this your whole
thing in life
um that's true I was diagnosed a second
grader in the early 70s but back then
they thought children outgrew it so
after sixth grade they just cut you off
that was it that's right so you've been
wrestling with this forever did you get
dishonorably discharged
no I'm honorably discharged in fact I
earned an Army Commendation Medal I was
an expert on the M16 I have other
rewards um all right so hold on hold on
you are able to take apart fix put back
together and fire an M16 with
extraordinary Precision correct
um yes I was very good at it you're able
to follow directions in a way when you
are actually engaged in a task in a way
that is second to none very few people
on the planet
can laser in with that ability and focus
on that particular task like you can
true or false
um that's true that's true
so I don't want to hear any nonsense
about your brain is broken
that you have a label that you've got
some sort of dysfunction
okay you do have regulation issues and
as a card-carrying member of the how do
you stay employed ADHD Club I would like
to welcome you to Our Gang officially
okay
[Laughter]
so
um you are putting a lot of bricks in
your own backpack for no reason other
than the fact that you have been told
throughout your life as much of a as
many of us in America have been told
that there is a difference between
people who turn wrenches for a living
and people who
write briefs in a law in a courtroom for
a living and people who do quote unquote
work where they have to tuck their
shirts in and iron their clothes for a
living
there is no difference there is work and
it all has value
um yes you're right
um my father uh was Blue Collar
um I grew up in a blue-collar type of
atmosphere uh learned a lot under him
um but
you also learned
we actually we do the real work around
here those white collar folks they just
that's what you learned my dad was a cop
I did too I learned that too
right like those guys are sitting in
those places with their suits on and
then when I got a suit on I was like
those guys work hard
it's a different kind of work they just
they have more access to more to better
alcohol to numb it all with but like
that job's hard too so what you're gonna
find is as as a as a MSW an MBA as a
leader
leadership's hard
like dealing with the struggles of
people's hard balancing all the budgets
across all that's hard
and so there's not a difference there
this new position
um it'll be my um first um is with the
Adult Protective Services I'm going to
be an investigative caseworker wonderful
so here's what you're going to be really
good at I'm guessing you are going to be
incredible at connecting with your staff
you are going to be the most loved
supervisor you're going to be incredible
showing up on a scene and sitting down
with somebody who or a family that has
to make a hard decision about
putting one of their uh elderly family
members in a home or in a place or
getting you're going to be amazing at
that and you are going to be a nightmare
at case notes
is that true
that's true you're gonna have like
Little Bits of Paper or like a yellow
pad and then you're gonna go from yellow
pad to an iPad and from an iPad to like
a special Journal
it's that's going to be the hard part
right is the is the the businessy parts
making sure your reports are done and
they're written up so that when you go
to court which you inevitably will you
can look like you're an adult right you
see what I'm saying that's gonna be the
hard part is that fair
um yes
um I'm one of those um I'll
procrastinate on something until the
last second to build up the adrenaline
to get it done
um and I have really a terrible time
with a sense of time
that my my wife my wife calls it my
magic time
that's cute she says you're the only
person I've ever met who gets in the
shower at 804 and gets out of the shower
at 8 15 and they're really mad
that they're going to be late to the
eight o'clock meeting
that's 30 minutes away
like she's like I don't know like you
have the strangest it's 7 58 and I'm
like no that's cool there's not an eight
there I got time to shower brush my
teeth and shave and sing a few songs and
then drive to work I'll get coffee too
on the way stop the dry cleaner and then
I get to work and it's 8 40. and I'm mad
at the time like I'm like the clock
screwed me somehow
I I dude I am with you I am with you
and you're so glad you understand oh god
dude it's it's like uh I was with um I
was with James child the former producer
we were having that uh we're having
dinner the other day together
and we were talking about something and
we had somewhere to be and I just kept
talking and talking and it was like the
light bulb went on for him and he looked
at me and goes you literally experienced
time differently than I do and I was
like I think so and he because I could
feel it in his body he was like we gotta
go we gotta go and I was like dude we're
in the middle of a hard conversation
let's just keep talking this is great
and that's when he realized oh you are
feeling this whole thing different than
me it just is so here's our
responsibility
I can't be late all the time
because it's disrespectful to people
that I care about and that I love and
who are other professionals
and so
I have to do the best I can to either
hire somebody who keeps me accountable
if I can do that in my current job
I have to create systems that I never
deviate from regardless of quote unquote
and here's what's bad about ADHD folks
how we feel
because we feel so heavy we feel so
strongly about things
yeah so I will exercise regardless of
how I feel unless I'm at a point of
fatigue where I I can cross a line and
now I've been doing it long enough now I
know I literally didn't work out this
morning because I've reached a fatigue
level that if I work out I'm gonna get
sick and then I'm gonna be out for three
days I know that about myself and so I
took this morning off I'll get it in
this afternoon but I took this morning
off that's okay but 99 of the time my
feelings don't get a vote in the
mornings
I will I will do this at this time I'll
do this and I've had to practice it
practice practice practice practice
if you filter your practices through I
have this thing
it's never gonna work
okay okay keep this phrase in your mind
it's a context not an excuse
okay you are going to be more chaotic
and you are going to be more loving when
you get there than anybody else
you're going to struggle with deadlines
and your reports are going to be better
than anybody's else's
okay so you're bringing a lot to the
table too
um your mission in life is not to not be
so uh ADHD your mission in life is to
get things in on time we're going to
focus on the thing not the label
we're going to do a we're going to do a
awesome job whether we are reassembling
an M16
or whether we are writing case notes
at the at the nursing home
because we just do excellent work that's
just who we are
not absolutely does that make sense
it makes perfect sense and I'm so so
glad you put it that way
um really
um I'll be honest that
um being told that just two weeks before
graduation and then of course you have
all of the emotions and nostalgia in
your life of wow I finally made it and
this is going on
um but then I had that then I had this
inertia for a while I was too afraid to
look for a job
um because I didn't know so there was a
lot of that going on as well but I
finally decided I haven't worked since
January and I said I really really need
to get going on this I've just got to
stop being afraid I have noticed the
difference with the Ritalin which I'm
really glad for oh dude ritalin's in
yeah ritalin's an amplifier
here's the thing here's the demon of
Ritalin it works
it worked same as cocaine cocaine works
it works great and then it kills you
right alcohol you're sad alcohol shuts
that thing off it helps you forget and
then it takes everything else with you
with it right so riddle like uh I'm not
gonna be somebody who tells a 58 year
old who's entering into a new job who's
had a lifelong war with ADHD to not take
um medicine I'm not gonna do that that's
cruel okay if you find some relief from
Ritalin which you will I can't imagine a
scenario where you won't
um where you will find some relief good
in that relief
I want you to begin to practice setting
up
um
systems
as the great James Clear says we fall to
the strength of our systems
meaning
if I wake up every day hoping I feel
like exercising I'm never gonna do it
but if I've built my morning routine
around 45 minutes of being in my
personal gym and I've over the last
three years I've bought some equipment
in my personal gym the system of my home
is John's downstairs from 5 15 to 6
o'clock AM
then even no matter what I feel I'm
going to fall to my system my kids will
ask me I thought you were working out my
wife would be like what are you doing up
here this is when you exercise like the
whole system is designed for me to work
out during that time we will fall to
those systems so while the the voices
are quieter I had one buddy tell me
who's an adult who started taking
Ritalin things about 50. he said it was
like he didn't realize he'd been
trying to learn and have conversations
in a stadium full of people his entire
life
and then he said it finally sounded like
everyone stopped talking for the first
time in his life
and he was like oh wow that's that's
what he described it as okay
and
I think the last numbers I heard I'm
gonna be off here a little bit but 3 4
75 percent of college age students are
taking some sort of stimulant
that's insane oh wow okay so it's
there's an abuse side of this too here's
what I want you to do I want you to look
at this as the adjunct that it is not
the savior
okay okay it's an outstanding support
especially for someone in your situation
to be able to finally okay everybody
stop yelling wow now I can do the work
is that cool
that's cool
um one good thing about the VA they're
extremely strict with Controlled
Substances that's right that's right
um so I do have to take your analysis
test
um blood work make sure that I'm doing
fine I have to ask for it every month
it's not automatically refilled right
um I have to go in three months for
assessments constantly so it's not just
like oh I'm just getting it and doing
what I want oh yeah yeah absolutely not
you know what like from what you're
telling me and again I'm not a
psychiatrist a psychologist anything
like I it makes sense it makes total
sense and if you were my mom I'd high
five you I wouldn't think I would be
like I don't know am I like good for you
okay
um
I am of all the things you've told me
the thing I'm most concerned for you
is you have lived your entire life
trying to chase down the right label for
you
and listen to me so carefully you don't
need a freaking label to tell you that
you're incredible
and nobody's ever told you that Diane
um
I have been told that um I've had a hard
time believing it okay
I stand corrected you've not believed it
it's time you're not your anxiety you're
not your ADHD you're not your honorable
discharge you're not your veteran status
those are things you've experienced
those are things you have done those are
parts of your life you are dying
my friend from Santa Fe New Mexico
who's entering into yet another rad
Adventure
being a leader in a job that serves the
least of these in our communities and
struggling families and a bunch of new
professionals and you were selected to
enter into that world
because you're good at it
you're worthy of being loved my sister
regardless of the labels
stay on track with your doctor stay on
track with your counselor good for you
good for you good for you I'm proud of
you
White Collar Blue Collar whatever it is
worked to be excellent and remember it's
a context
not an excuse
still gotta get that work done Diane
we'll be rooting for you we'll be right
back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own in your past change your
future at John deloney.com
all right we are back and uh Kelly
picked the song of the day it's the song
I sing every time she uh chooses yet
again to wear overalls to work as though
we're on a farm
songs by the great journey made famous
by Glee
Don't Stop Believing
is that is that the one they sing don't
you dare say that that song was made
famous by Glee that's so offensive
I love that show y'all are the worst
Don't Stop Believing
just a small town girl
dressed in overalls living in a lonely
world she always wears overalls just
took the midnight train going anywhere
just a city boy born and raised in South
Detroit Eight Mile he took the midnight
train going anywhere
singer in a smoky room the smell of wine
and cheap perfume for a smile they can
share the night it goes on and on and on
strangers waiting up and down the
boulevard their Shadows searching in the
night
Don't Stop Believing hold on
Don't Stop Believing I was gonna say
something prophetic and then I just
thought you sound like an idiot baloney
hey love you guys see you soon
[Music]